j'ai trouvé vraiment très bon il
vieillit bien
c'est mieux que ça je pense que d'abord
il révèle une bonne nature il est
bienveillant ira aujourd'hui oui c'est
vrai travail sur le bonheur
et puis c'est presque devenu un
philosophe quand les jours mais il a
beaucoup d'heures il a beaucoup de
sagesse je vais faire l'année politique
ce soir juste parce qu'il y avait une
place libre
non c'est bien je vais vous dire un truc
j'aime bien que vous ayez dis ça parce
que c'est pas du tout politiquement
correct ce que vous avez dit mais ça va
rien vous rapporter sur sarkozy oui et
ça prouve que vous êtes un type devrait
re que vous êtes animés d'un désir de
pacification de paix d'amour alors oui
sans doute et un mot important mais je
crois que vous l'avez en vous je te
remercie pas très bon bah c'est bien
passé donc bon soir
vous êtes avocat de profession et vous
avez été pendant 20 ans l'avocat de
jacques chirac
bravo les jeunes est en taule en même
temps
qu'est ce qu'un bon dossier
honnêtement c'était un bon dossier ouais
un avocat qui commence et brasparts
honnêtement ça pue auquel mme vilaine
appréciation alors ensuite j'ai été
ministre délégué aux libertés locales
c'est à dire quoi sa mini
décentralisation ah ouais adacore et
puis ministre délégué à l'industrie de
2004 2005 et à l'arrivée de villepin
thierry breton ne vous veux pas comme
ministre de l'industrie vous refusez
l'aménagement du territoire qu'on vous
propose
et vous devenez donc conseiller
politique de nicolas sarkozy
avec comme slogan à moi le ministère de
la parole voilà et c'est également le
titre du livre d'entretiens avec
emmanuel kessler journalistes à public
sénat la chaîne parlementaire vous
publiée à l'archipel voilà alors en fait
les départs du gouvernement au moment de
l'arrivée de dominique de villepin
vous dites pour vous c'est un symbole
d'une politique de changement de cap
suite à l'échec du référendum mais en
fait c'est la même chose quoi jura par
un vil pas c'est la continuité quoi
quand même une volonté de rattrapage ont
perdu oui on a mis le turbo
oui mais dans la même direction pour
vous villepin c'est le verbe
oui c'est pas mal le vert ben oui ça va
mal mais enfin par exemple quand il dit
cette année pas de petites phrases
vous vous dites j'ai effectivement
villepin ne fait pas de petites phrases
il fait des phrases creuses
je dis que quand on ne veut pas quand on
se plaint des petites phrases c'est
souvent qu'on aime les grandes phrases
foule j'ai remarqué que dans cette
émission on aime bien les petites
phrases alors vous attaquez le bouquin
avec vos origines arméniennes votre père
est né là bas comme dirait doc gynéco
votre père donc est arrivé en france à
l'âge de 18 ans ingénieur en fonderie et
il a inventé la cocotte minute quand
même oui mais n'a pas fait fortune alors
les gens non annoncés tels rival c'est
le concurrent
tu confonds avec youtube
alors sur la turquie vous dites en tous
les cas qu'elle n'a toujours pas reconnu
le génocide arménien et qu'en turquie
c'est toujours un délit d' appeler ça un
génocide
donc vous êtes contre l'entrée de la
turquie dans l'europe voilà pas
seulement pour soi oui pas seulement
pour ça parce que pour vous c'est un peu
la turquie aujourd'hui c'est un peu
l'espagne de franco le portugal de
salazar qu'elle n'est pas démocratique
voilà voilà c'est tout oui et puis c'est
suffisant et puis à chypre ya chip ya
chip qui est partagé en deux et vous
dites le dernier mur de la honte en
europe
il est à à nicosie ce que j -c que
l'armée turque occupe le territoire
européen
ouais et que ne peut pas faire entrer
dans l'union européenne un pays qui
commence par nous envoyer son armée faut
déjà qu'ils retirent leurs seins mais
pour qu'on puisse discuter ça me paraît
raisonnable non ensuite vous expliquer
dans ce bouquin sur votre appartenance à
occident au mouvement d'extrême droite
dans lequel il y avait à la madeleine
gérard longuet alors vous dites
j'étais un occident en fait pour
défendre l'algérie française face à
l'époque à l'avancée de l'islam et passe
le communiste il c'est toi qui ferrer
fait faire des erreurs à nicolas aubé tu
sais j'ai fait beaucoup de conneries on
m'a vue images mégalopole de faire
cette appartenance à occident alors oui
je me suis trompé je déjà dit je croyais
à l'algérie française trouvé ça
patriotique comme j'étais un français de
fraîche date en plus j'avais envie de
donner des gages je me suis trompé
j'avais 20 ans je ne laisserai personne
dire que c'est le plus bel âge de la vie
disant que oui je me suis totalement
trompé j'ai pas pris conscience à
l'époque du droit des peuples à disposer
d'eux-mêmes ansa ouais vous n'étiez pas
occident pour défendre la pureté de la
race quoi ben pour moi c'est difficile
parce que je suis déjà mélangé
alors dans ce livre vous n'êtes pas
tendre pour jean pierre raffarin vous
dit que c'était le règne de la
communication vous dit quand il y avait
des séminaires à l'époque on aborder
jamais les questions de fond d'abord ont
trouvé le slogan et après on trouvait la
réforme qu'elle est avec lui je pense à
rien je dis mon expérience et je dis ce
que je pense pourtant que j'ai tjrs et
dans ce gouvernement je n'ai jamais
démissionné mais je suis parti ouais
vous on peut virer quand même non on
s'est pas entendus il voulait me garder
sur un strapontin et ça me faisait mal
aux fesses vous êtes bien la lampre dire
tout ce que vous voulez absolument
ça n'a pas de prix au sujet de chirac
vous dites il n'est pas de droite
dans tous les cas il ne se revendique
pas comme tel ouais c'est son doit
d'ailleurs
mais l'électorat de droite croit qu'il
l'est et lui dans sa vie il ne s'est
jamais affirmer comme tel car lellouche
n'étaient assis là y'a quelques temps
disait que chirac était radical
socialiste rad soc
mais je crois qu'il a raison mon
jugement d'ailleurs il est issu d'une
terre radicale socialiste et on est
toujours marquée par son terroir
d'élections je crois qu'il a raison le
look vous trouvez qu'il est rad soc
et en plus qui les démagos vous citer
une phrase dans votre bouquin en 94
chirac qui déclare je vous étonnerai
parma démagogie voyez nous a dit ça oui
pas seulement moi mais tu es très
nombreux et entendre cette phrase et il
nous a effectivement étonné viti surf
quoi sur l'air du temps il est toujours
d'accord avec le truc du moment quoi il
sait très bien récupéré c'est une
qualité d'ailleurs pour un homme
politique qui sait très bien récupérer
l'air du temps c'est vrai que en 86
j'ai fait moi avec lui une campagne sur
le printemps libéral
faisait photographier en chemise ouais
on nous explique ça se terminera mal le
libéralisme vous êtes sûr que chirac va
se représenter en 2007
non je dis simplement que il n'a renoncé
à rien jusqu'à la dernière seconde de
son mandat et que s'ils pouvaient le
ferai bien sûr il sera présente à ses
pas sur la situation politique le lui
permettent ses pas su alors on dit
souvent que si chirac veut se
représenter 6 pour échapper aux
poursuites mais on se déplace et alors
là par votre bouche nicolas sarkozy lui
dit que une fois son immunité levée ne
sera pas poursuivi non je pense que
c'est pas l'intérêt de la france d'abord
de s'amuser à poursuivre ces présidents
et qu'elle l'a jamais fait parce que
comme image internationale c'est pas
terrible bon et ensuite je crois qu'il
ya d'autant moins de raisons de le faire
que tout ce qu'on a tenté contre lui
dans ce domaine a toujours échoué parce
que c'était pas établie et qu'on lui a
fait quand même beaucoup de procès
d'intention l'avocate chirac qui parle
la corée je pense que ici la gagner
c'est aussi parce que il était innocent
même s'il a fait un autre avocat qu'il
était d'abord innocent ses jupes est qu
après quoi l'envié qu'ont la rupture
donc j'étais un partisan de sarkozy
voilà il faut il faut changer là il faut
tout changer
je pense que il faut un changement
profond et que par exemple le fait
d'être aussi habitué au chômage que nous
le sommes et d'un chômage très élevé
entre 9 et 10%
c'est à dire beaucoup plus que les eaux
il faut rompre avec ça le fait par
exemple est d'avoir un état très
dépensier
l'état dépense 25% de plus chaque année
que ce qu'il encaisse même personne peut
résister à ce régime
il faut rompre avec ça voilà donc le
modèle social français en fait c'est pas
un modèle puisque personne veut limiter
à l'étranger bah oui un modèle c'est
quelque chose que quelqu'un a limité le
nôtre personne d'autre que nous n'en
veut et même nous on se pose des
questions et favorable aux cpe la
métrique de villepin contrat de première
embauche
je pense que ça pourrait
que c'est une mesure de flexibilité qui
peut créer des emplois qui doit créer
des emplois peut-être aussi on peut
l'améliorer en renforçant l'indemnité
des personnes licenciées à vous êtes
libéral vous sur le plan économique
je suis libéral d'une manière générale
sur l'ensemble de la société c'est à
dire je suis aussi pour une plus grande
liberté dans la société
mais quand par exemple mittal veut
racheter à seller c'est à dire quand le
plus grand aciériste mondial qui est
indien il aurait acheté un aciéristes
européens
oui le libéralisme ce serait de laisser
faire normalement mais ça ne m'indigne
pains que mittal souhaite racheter car
c'est lorsque je trouve pas ça
scandaleux d'ailleurs arcelor et était
en train d'acheter une entreprise
canadienne au moment où il a été attaqué
par mittal donc nous aussi nous faisons
des au pea
donc on peut aussi en faire contre nous
ça ne me scandalise pas qui en est une
mais arcelor a aussi le droit de se
défendre oui mais pourquoi tout le monde
a parlé à ce moment-là de patriotisme
économique sur les dents le libéralisme
tout le monde a droit d'acheter tout le
monde mais moi ce que je crois être le
patriotisme économique c'est
l'attractivité du territoire c'est
l'implantation de l'activité sur notre
territoire
maintenant la nationalité de
l'entreprise qui fait travailler les
français je crois que cet accessoire
pourvu que ça se passe en france et
quand une entreprise française est
racheté par une entreprise étrangère le
risque c'est qu'elle s'en aille
oui ça c'est pas négligeable par exemple
quand toyota est installé à valenciennes
et créer 3000 emplois pour des français
c'est bien sa place quand alice par
pierre lellouche parle de syndrome
amélie poulain et vous de complexes
d'astérix ne veut dire quoi
c'est le déclin quoi oui je suis un
déclinologues comme divine ouais ouais
juste battre ça ça se constate je veux
dire le rayonnement de la france dans le
monde
il s'affaiblit par exemple en 1998 la
france est passée derrière l'angleterre
comme puissance économique et l'année
dernière les passer derrière la chine de
china grand pays mais enfin on n'en
finit pas de descendre les marches de
l'escalier on est combien là on est
sixième à ganges ception était 4e ben
voilà ça ça et ça va pas s'arranger pour
c'est quoi tous ces jeunes qui veulent
quitter la france pour aller s'établir
en angleterre ou ailleurs
c'est une interpellation pour nous dans
les années 50 les italiens s'en allait
venir en france ce qui pouvait pas vivre
chez eux l'économie ne permettait pas
les espagnols les portugais mais
maintenant ils vivent pas trop mal chez
eux sains et ils vivent tout cas
personne s'en va et c'est chez nous que
ça se parle il ya déjà une fuite des
capitaux et des années et une fuite des
cerveaux en france depuis des années ça
se voit non mais je crois que c'est
clair
merci pour les verges yannick noah lui
c'est pas pareil dit moi si sarkozy
passe je me casse je crois que c'est
déjà fait non ouais j'ai déjà cassé
cécilia sarkozy tcl new york elle aussi
mais leur venue mais j'y suis
l'anniversaire de nicolas qu'elle a
organisé la wii c'est sympa près il est
christian clavier ici
écoutez je vais pas vous faire le compte
rendu de la soirée était d'abord une
soirée privée comme un article dans le
parisien bah oui il ya toujours des gens
pour les raconter ce qui se passe et
gestion clavier lui demanderait l'aide
de droite vous tout dépend de ce que
vous mettez dans ce terme mais oui je
suis de droite
on va vérifier on va faire un droit de
test